[Musique]
le guide du célibataire de jean-bernard
effet ou comment rester salle au logis
est d'être heureux quand même seul pas
tant que cela au fond du coeur de tout
célibataire il y à un sentimental qui
sommeille un célibataire qui a décidé
d'être célibataire une bonne fois pour
toutes s'étaient pouvant pas c'est un
mec qui s'achète un petit lit moi j'ai
un grand lit c'est un type qui n'a que
une fourchette un couteau une petite
cuillère une assiette une tasse inverse
moi j'ai au contraire j'attends
quelqu'un qui viennent remplir l'espace
[Musique]
faut surtout pas qu'elle vienne dans une
cuisine faut surtout pas qu'elle ait
envie de faire la cuisine
il faut qu'elle en ait envie mais il
faut qu'on leur interdise à ce moment-là
ça les excite
bah oui elles ont envie de revenir c'est
le but recherché d'ailleurs jeu parce
qu'il ya ici tout ce qu'elles veulent et
qu'elles n'ont pas vous les laissez pas
du tout faire la cuisine
non on les appelle en leur disant est ce
que tu pourrais venir m'aider et dès
qu'elle arrive on leur interdit de
toucher à quoi que ce soit de toute
façon elles savent pas où sont passés
enfin où sont placés les ingrédients les
produits les machins alors ils vont
commencer à changer tout place le
lendemain matin quand elles seront
partis on retrouvera rien c'est
insupportable donc faux et deuxième elle
mange que l'on a préparé pour elle et
elle s'en vont mais elle ne touche à
rien surtout mais le truc du célibataire
solitaire la dame débarquer se dit ah là
là le pauvre il est tout seul je vais
m'occuper de lui je vais lui mijoter des
bonnes petites choses et comme ça il
s'attachera à moi avec vous ça marche
pas impossible de tout est prévu pour
que je n'ai pas besoin d'elle justement
moi je suis très très honnête j'ai pas
besoin d'une bonne pour me faire des
petits plats pour s'occuper de mon linge
pour nettoyer mon sol pour la faire la
vaisselle
c'est horrible de traiter une femme
comme ça sinon ils servier marié oui
sûrement
une femme s'est pas fait pour ça est-ce
qu'il est ordonné dre ar d'année vous
devez pas sans arrêt ranger derrière lui
et non sauf si sa veste et ses pantalons
site où est son linge sale vous en
occuper non c'est lui que les gardes et
les l'afp qu'il l'avait lui-même
non je suis crois que c'est sa maman que
ça coupait des sept loges c'est à dire
que vous et sa maman vous êtes les deux
femmes qui ont de l'importance dans sa
vie oui je crois
parlez moi de votre maman maman elle est
bien parce que
elle s'entend très bien finalement avec
toutes les dom que j'ai connu et même
quand moi j'arrête de les voir continuer
à aller voir un agent de club le club
des ex de la mère de jean bernard il
vous débarquer chez lui à l'improviste
et il pas parfois des rencontres gênante
je viens en général vers les 2h 2h30
la plupart du temps il est pas là je
viens prendre son l'âge et je repars
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la vie
qu'ils mènent
s'il a choisi c'est qu'elle doit dû
plaire et j'en suis ravie moi aussi j'ai
pas renoncer au mariage
je renonce je renonce pas d'ailleurs
j'attends je rêve finalement peut-être
de trouver malgré tout mais clowneries
méhul free j'aimerais bien trouver une
femme qui me marier fonder un foyer ça
peut sembler bête mais c'est vrai
j'aimerais bien avoir une vraie femme
qui passe des vrais enfants dans ces
cas-là fold en faut beaucoup gêné au
moins 4 ou 5 mais vous rester
célibataire parce que vous êtes trop
exigeant oui je demande beaucoup aux
autres parce que je me demande beaucoup
à moi parce qu'on me demande beaucoup à
moi donc c'est vrai que je demande je
demande tellement de choses à une femme
que je sais pas si c'est possible
j'admets pas et j'accepte très
difficilement les justement le petit
bout de salade entre les dents c'est
quand même très dur et malheureusement
il ya toujours un petit bout de ça entre
les danses ça qui est en baisse
bon sang mais c'est bien sûr un
célibataire est un idéaliste mais celui
là en plus est un perfectionniste qui a
tout prévu
puis
une différence est indispensable à
célibataire oui obligatoire pas
obligatoire de vie d'avant ça dépend des
moyens mais qui dit terrasse 10 ans
l'oeil qui dit soleil dit chaleur sinon
vient pas sur la terrasse qui dit soleil
et chaleur 10 maillots de bain qui dit
maillot de bain dit monokini qui dit
monokini dit le plus gros est fait ça
c'est un peu clinique chirurgicale cette
salle de bain c'est pas très engageant
mais c'est pas fait pour être engageant
c'est fait pour se laver une salle de
bain alors celle là est fait pour se
laver et uniquement ça c'est à dire
qu'il ya un lavabo
j'ai placé très haut c'est comme je suis
grand on avait les mains la fidh avancé
un problème pour les naines puisque
elles peuvent pas se laver ou à peine
les dents ça ceci dit on peut pas se
laver les dents parce qu'il n'ya pas de
brosse à dents pour même problème pour
le miroir parce que comme c'est fait
juste pour ma tête et je me rase pas
donc c'est assez aux dons qu'elles
peuvent pas se voir absolument
impossible pour l installer des petits
pots des trucs parce que tout de suite
entre le noir et le blanc ça ferait
ça irait part donc pas de place dans le
petit pot pas de poubelles nul pas très
important d'habitude toujours une petite
poubelle blanche mignonne petit port ou
dans lequel on peut mettre les vieux
coton non là ya pas de vieux coton
puisqu'il ya pas de poubelle donc à
chaque fois il faut prendre les trucs le
descendre dans la poubelle en barrer
cuisine c'est compliqué donc elle se
sert pas que ça parce que si je
comprends bien si elles installent leurs
petits pots et leur coton elle commence
vraiment à s'installer au nom impossible
impossible de s'installer d'année les
petits pots etc autant parce que qui dit
petit pot et quand on dit un sac pour
amener ça donc le jeu on lui dit qu'il
faut plus qu advienne faut qu'elle
ramène le sac ça fait déménagement donc
ce sont furieuses donc impossible donc
si je comprends bien une fois qu'elles
sont passées dans la chambre on leur
demande juste une chose c'est de partir
aussi vite
oui si possible la nuit pour pas qu'on
les voit le matin pourquoi parce que
c'est déjà suffisamment dur parfois la
nuit pour pas en plus avoir à les subir
le matin bon ça marche ce que vous
voulez justement ce que je veux c'est
qu'elle s'en aille
après juste après consommation dont se
parent consommation après carl un
intense mois face est un peu comme une
épine exclame les utiliser à prendre
mais j'ai pas tout
pas tout il y en a qui servent deux fois
comme les kleenex
je suis célibataire il vaut mieux que je
me dise que c'est bien parce que sinon
je vivre un enfer que le jour où je
rencontre celle qui formidable j'écris
un autre bouquin
[Musique]